et c'est parti pour une nouvelle saison
des théâtres un programme convoité avec
le plus grand soin avec Pascal Montrouge
et toute son équipe une présentation qui
a débuté avec de l'énergie celle de la
jeunesse des danseurs de
mon gravites sur une mise en scène de
Jérôme Brabant des sauts improbables
périlleux et une danse venue tout droit
de la rue sur de la musique classique la
magie au père
je Barbie du théâtre de Champfleury à la
grande scène il n'y a que quelques pas
que parce qu'elles vont les aider à
faire si je ne sort qui se sont produits
dans le cadre du festival Toto total
ferrant cette fois-ci la démonstration
l'étendue de leur talent sur la
prestigieuse scène du théâtre de
Champfleury
de la danse mais également de la musique
du théâtre des opéras le cocktail
éclectique permettra à chacun de piocher
d'apprécier même si le mot d'ordre est à
la découverte à l'image du groupe
sauvage qui a pris une résidence au
Théâtre avec Sandrine Ebra a préparé un
spectacle sur-mesure pour les
spectateurs réunionnais
spécialement pour la date du théâtre
planner on a travaillé sur un spectacle
sous la houlette de Madame Sandrine et
donc ce sera un prototype tout neuf pour
pour le public qui viendra au planeur
spécialement pour le planning on va dire
c'est une très belle rencontre qui ne
nous rajeunit pas mais qui fait toujours
le même effet celle du produit s'il y a
longtemps avec polyclone et marie-amoute
on sera quatre
Henri Claude de banjoie Jean-Louis Bègue
à la basse jouer à la Manitou à la
batterie moi au champ et il y aura des
surprises
regarde souvent le temps est gris sous
le ciel de Paris
loin de ton pays
loin de tes amis
viendra vite la nostalgie qui brisera ta
vie bien dans les soucis loin de ton
pays
on retrouve aussi dans cette
programmation midi Gerville qui revient
avec son métissage de musique il
présente la location ce nouvel album au
public réunionnais
chacune dans un registre bien précis
la porte il va
les maladies
n'importe histoire
unifié ensemble
dans des fois la vie foulant lourderie
de saison après saison c'est de montrer
toute la diversité du monde la diversité
de notre monde donc comme maladie
Christine salam mais aussi saodage
Gauthier mais aussi en théâtre avec
Nicolas Givrand Daniel Waro qui va faire
une pièce de théâtre pour le jeune
public pour le Toto total parce qu'il
faut pas oublier aussi le jeune public
de ses autres azote qu'il faut passer ça
et beaucoup d'autres choses au programme
de cette saison où ça nous ça va entre
autres une saison qui aura comme tel
d'affiches en pluriel et s'il fallait en
trouver plusieurs Christine insalem et
Lucrèce Borgia jouer magistralment par
Béatrice Dalle rendez-vous sur le site
des théâtres pour télécharger la
programmation